Jeremy corbyn's time as labor party
leader was fraught with claims of
anti-Semitism which split the party
today kirstama wants to show the
arguments are over China by labor MP for
barking day Margaret Hodge one of those
was affected by the rise high so to see
you thanks for coming in really
appreciate it
um Your Leader will say later on today
in a speech that the party has changed
what proof is that
well let's just take the anti-Semitism
first that one of the first phone calls
that
testosterama made after he became
elected leader was to be and to other
Jews who had suffered under the time of
Jew hate with corbyn and he promised us
then that he would show demonstrate zero
tolerance to anti-Semitism and he's
acted so we've got a completely new
complaints mechanism with much speedier
it's much more comfortable and
transparency transparent people have
been expelled from the labor party in
their hundreds and we've had intensive
training of labor party members and
decision makers to ensure that they are
totally aware of what constitutes
anti-Semitism that's one bit but the
party's changed much more fundamentally
if you think about things like our
attitude and the economy to businesses
the way that we approach business that's
a complete transformation from the days
of corbyn or if you think about us on
the global stage that you're looking at
now we are now firmly working with NATO
and with the West to ensure stability
for our values in the globe in the
global world all that is a massive
transformational change it's not
superficial yeah
yeah if he was so appalled by the way
the party was behaving under uh Jeremy
corbyn why didn't he stop it at the time
he was part of the cabinet I think that
time was horribly difficult putting
myself back into it people had to take
personal decisions as hard as to how
they were going to respond to the
appalling circumstances in which we
found ourselves wrong isn't it and you
know it it you have to stand up and be
counted as a politician and he was part
of that cabinet and he let it go on well
let me just say this that some members
felt so terrible about it they left I
was among those that those people that
decided to find it from within and uh
care decided to fight it privately and I
think those were really really really
difficult decisions to take at the time
but what I can say to you is Care's
leadership since he became elected as
either a labor party you just can't
quarrel with it if you'd said to me okay
two years ago when we had that terrible
report horrific day with the ehrc saying
that we were guilty of Jew hate if you'd
said to me two years on things will be
different and you'll be given a clean
bit of Health I wouldn't have believed
you so I'm proud to say that I was wrong
I lived through the age is when we were
fighting militant and it took much much
longer than and I think the reason we'd
be unable to manage it much more quickly
now is actually that clear determined
detailed sort of absolutely driven
leadership that we've had from kirstana
yeah since he took over apparently it's
reported there have been 700
anti-Semitism cases has the problem
really gone away no and I'll tell you
why it won't have totally gone away if
you allow something like that anti-jew
hate to move from the fringes of your
party into the mainstream it takes time
to transform the culture we've put
everything in place it's a zillion times
better we're beginning to see things
emerging you know I talk about flowers
blooming so Barnet which was an ERA with
a very strong population voted labor in
the local elections were beginning to
get stunningly strong labor people
Jewish people standing as Labor
candidates but is it all it dealt with
no we've got to keep our foot on the
accelerator and transforming that
culture to show to be restored to the
party that I joined because I am a Jew
and because I fight racism to restore it
to those values its basic values will
always take time
it was a dark chapter in the party's
history will it always be marred by that
I think we'll get no I don't think it
will be I think people now are so
focused on providing an alternative uh
party and government that will provide
hope that you know will ensure that
we're not corrupt which is uh the the
things that we're facing now that really
will invest in health and education and
deal with the cost of living crisis I
think I think it will
um it will diminish but let me just say
this I don't want us to forget it
completely because I don't want it ever
to happen again here's a tricky one for
the end
um what should happen to Jeremy corbyn
Oh I thought you know diet about that I
think I have absolute
can't think of any circumstances in
which Jeremy corbyn could ever stand as
a labor candidate again still a member
of the party isn't he he's still a
member of the party I'm actually allowed
to be
um well I think the most important thing
is that he will not stand as a candidate
and so it's it's a matter of his own
doing he's been the master of his own
destiny he knew what he did uh he knows
what it is would he be banned from the
party well I think the party's moved on
actually ironically I think I've moved
on the parties where the country's moved
on they're not voting for us again and
if you're somebody who believe who
promotes anti-jew hate if you're
somebody who thinks that uh we shouldn't
be talking to business
if your party if you're somebody who is
anti-native I think you should be
walking away from the labor party it's
not your TV banned from the party why
why are you so hesitant because I'm not
being hesitant I just think at the
moment you know it's a matter for him
he's got to buy into the new gender I
don't think he does I don't think he'll
feel comfortable there I think there's
no circumstances in which he will be a
candidate again for the labor party will
have lots of stunning people who will
want to take over that seat uh and it
then it's up to him can he be loyal to
this transformed party there's
fundamental changed party that is now uh
standing you know to be the government
in Britain okay thank you very much good
to see you thank you